From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Danger is all around us, in ways we do not even suspect.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台（Public Radio International），这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。危险无处不在，以我们甚至无法察觉的方式。
Crime blotter. The Athens Daily News , Athens, Georgia. Athens-Clarke police investigated several weekend burglaries, including one in which a burglar stopped to prepare a sandwich. A Cobb Street resident told police someone cut out the window screen between 10:00 AM and 10:45 PM Saturday. But nothing appeared to be missing inside, except enough bread and sandwich meat to make a sandwich, the resident told police. The incident is similar to several other break-ins in the past few days, including one Wednesday in which a burglar drank a bottle of beer, and another Tuesday, in which a burglar prepared a turkey sandwich.
犯罪记录。雅典《每日新闻》，乔治亚州雅典。雅典-克拉克警方调查了周末发生的几起入室盗窃案，其中一起案件中，窃贼中途停下来做了个三明治。一名科布街居民告诉警方，周六上午10点到晚上10点45分之间，有人割开了窗纱。但该居民告诉警方，屋里似乎什么都没丢，除了足够做一份三明治的面包和肉。该事件与过去几天的几起入室盗窃案类似，包括周三一起案件中窃贼喝了一瓶啤酒，以及周二另一起案件中窃贼做了一个火鸡三明治。
We think of crime as a kind of monolithic, menacing presence, a shadowy threat, lurking, faceless. But there are many kinds of crimes and many kinds of criminals. Take these crimes, ripped from today's headlines.
我们认为犯罪是一种单一的、危险的存在，一种潜伏的、无面的阴影威胁。但犯罪种类繁多，罪犯也各不相同。看看这些从今日头条中摘录的犯罪新闻吧。
Crime blotter. The Anacortes American , Anacortes, Washington. A woman's persistence rewarded her with a shoplifting citation after she attempted to steal four 40-ounce bottles of beer, one at a time, from the Old Salt's convenience store on Skyline Way. The owner of the store told police that the woman, who appeared intoxicated to begin with, entered the store and went to the beer cooler, where she selected a 40-ounce Lucky Lager and left without paying. The owner quickly followed the woman and brought her back in the store. Undaunted by her apprehension, the woman again returned to the cooler, selected another Lucky, and again walked out, closely followed by the owner, who once again returned her to the store.
犯罪记录。《阿纳科特斯美国人报》，华盛顿州阿纳科特斯。一名女子在试图从天际路的“老盐”便利店偷走四瓶40盎司啤酒（一次偷一瓶）后，因其坚持不懈而收到了一张入店行窃的传票。店主告诉警方，这名女子最初看起来就喝醉了，她进入店内走到啤酒冷藏柜前，拿了一瓶40盎司的幸运拉格啤酒，没付钱就走了。店主迅速跟上，把她带回了店里。女子并未因被抓而气馁，她再次回到冷藏柜，又拿了一瓶幸运啤酒，再次走了出去，店主紧随其后，再次将她带回店里。
When the owner went to her phone to call police, the persistent woman again jumped to the beer cooler, this time selecting a 40-ounce bottle of Milwaukee's Best, and started drinking down the brew as she left the store. The owner followed and once again returned the shoplifter to her store to wait for police.
当店主去打电话报警时，这位执着的女子再次跳到啤酒冷藏柜前，这次拿了一瓶40盎司的密尔沃基最好啤酒，并一边走出店门一边喝了起来。店主跟在后面，再次将这名窃贼带回店里等待警察。
Apparently still a little parched, the woman returned to the cooler for a fourth time, and grabbed a 40-ounce bottle of St.  Ides. This time, however, she didn't bother leaving the store and chugged it down where she stood. The woman was cited for third degree theft, and then taken home and turned over to her husband.
这名女子显然还是有点口渴，第四次回到冷藏柜，拿了一瓶40盎司的圣伊德啤酒。然而这一次，她没费心离开店，就在原地把酒喝光了。这名女子因三级盗窃罪被传讯，随后被送回家交给丈夫。
Stories about crime, no matter how simple, are a kind of snapshot of someone's life and their problems at a certain moment. Through our crimes, we express who we are.
关于犯罪的故事，无论多么简单，都是一个人在特定时刻的生活及其问题的缩影。通过我们的罪行，我们表达了我们是谁。
Crime blotter. The Anacortes American , Anacortes, Washington. Police arrested a 22-year-old Anacortes man Saturday morning, July 11, for causing a disturbance after he allegedly hurled potato salad at kids attending a festival, and, in the presence of a police officer, threatened to kill the operator of an inflatable obstacle course. The man told police he was upset because the festival, which started at 10:00 AM, was disrupting his sleep. The man was booked into Skagit County Jail on a charge of disorderly conduct.
犯罪记录。《阿纳科特斯美国人报》，华盛顿州阿纳科特斯。警方于7月11日周六上午逮捕了一名22岁的阿纳科特斯男子，原因是他涉嫌向参加节日活动的儿童投掷土豆沙拉，并在一名前来调查的警官面前威胁要杀死一个充气障碍设施的操作员。该男子告诉警方，他很生气，因为从上午10点开始的节日活动打扰了他的睡眠。该男子因扰乱治安罪被关进斯卡吉特县监狱。
Today on our radio program, stories about crime and the many varying reasons for committing crimes. Each of the people on today's show chose a crime that is particular to him or her. And it's actually impossible to imagine any of them committing the crimes that the others committed. When we choose to break the law, we choose carefully. It's as much a Rorschach test as anything in our lives.
今天我们的广播节目将讲述关于犯罪以及实施犯罪的各种原因的故事。今天节目中的每一个人都选择了对自己而言独特的犯罪方式。而且实际上，无法想象他们中的任何一个人会去实施其他人所犯下的罪行。当我们选择触犯法律时，我们会谨慎选择。这就像我们生活中的任何事情一样，是一场罗夏墨迹测试。
Act One of our program today, Your Good Girl's Gonna Go Bad, the story of the kind of criminal who somehow believes, through all her crimes, that she's a good person with good intentions. Act Two, You'll Pay, a man who says that part of the thrill of robbing banks is the pleasure of scaring people. Act Three, Grandma Takes a Fall. Her kids don't know. Her grandkids don't know. But hanging around with a bunch of old people at the senior citizens center turns out to be much less interesting than going out and stealing. Stay with us.
节目第一幕，《好姑娘要变坏》，讲述的是那种通过所有的犯罪行为，仍然认为自己是个心地善良的好人的罪犯。第二幕，《你会付出代价》，一个男人说抢劫银行的快感部分来自于吓唬人的乐趣。第三幕，《祖母跌倒了》。她的孩子们不知道。她的孙子们不知道。但事实证明，在老年中心和一群老人混在一起，远不如出去偷东西有趣。请继续收听。
Act One, Your Good Girl's Gonna Go Bad. When she was 21, Julia Sweeney moved from Spokane, Washington, to Los Angeles to follow a dream, a dream so many people have, of landing a job in accounting. She had a fresh, new accounting degree from the University of Washington.
第一幕，《好姑娘要变坏》。朱莉娅·斯威尼21岁时从华盛顿州斯波坎搬到了洛杉矶，去追寻许多人都有的梦想——找到一份会计工作。她刚从华盛顿大学获得了新的会计学位。
But the dream accounting job that she had been promised at MGM Studios fell through. And she ended up working as an assistant bartender at a downtown hotel, meaning at various parties and events in the hotel, she sold tickets for drinks. And then customers would carry these tickets over to the real bartenders, who were all young, African American men, and not deemed trustworthy enough to handle cash themselves.
但她在米高梅影城被承诺的那份梦寐以求的会计工作告吹了。最终，她在市中心的一家酒店当了一名助理调酒师，这意味着在酒店的各种聚会和活动中，她负责卖酒水票。然后顾客会拿着票去找真正的调酒师，那些人都是年轻的非裔美国男性，他们被认为不够值得信赖，不能经手现金。
Among other things, this turned out to be a bad piece of judgment on the part of hotel management. Julia estimates that she herself stole between $10,000 and $15,000 in cash in this job, though she started as an honest employee.
除其他事项外，事实证明这是酒店管理层判断失误。朱莉娅估计她自己在工作中偷了1万到1.5万美元现金，尽管她刚开始是个诚实的员工。
I started out very conscientiously. And there was some accounting involved, because you would write down the number of the first ticket and the number of the last ticket. And then you had to have the amount of money for the amount of tickets you sold. And I had--
我开始时非常认真。而且其中涉及一些会计工作，因为你要写下第一张票的号码和最后一张票的号码。然后你必须要有和你售出的票量相对应的金额。而我有……
Did you actually think that at the time, well, there is some accounting involved in this? Was that a thought?
当时你真的有想过，“嗯，这其中涉及一些会计工作”吗？你有过这种想法吗？
Yeah, actually I did. I thought, well, I like numbers. Now, I'm such a different person than the person I was who liked numbers, that it's hard for me to even believe I ever had that thought. But yes, at the time, I was looking forward to the number part of it. So I had three different kinds of tickets. I had beer and wine tickets, I had soft drink tickets, and I had mixed drink tickets. And they were like $2.75 and $2.50 and $1.25 or something. And they were different colors.
是的，实际上我有。我想，嗯，我喜欢数字。现在，我与那个喜欢数字的自己已经大相径庭，以至于很难相信我曾经有过那种想法。但确实，当时我很期待数字那部分。我有三种不同的票。我有啤酒和葡萄酒票，我有软饮票，还有混合饮料票。它们分别是2.75美元、2.50美元和1.25美元左右。而且颜色也不一样。
And so I started selling these tickets. And it was just many, many hours of sitting at a card table. And people would come up, and you'd just make change and sell tickets. And well, to me, what started it was that they wouldn't pay for my parking at the hotel while I worked.
于是我开始卖这些票。那是坐在卡片桌前度过的漫长时光。人们走过来，你只是找零和卖票。嗯，对我来说，开始的原因是他们在我不工作时拒绝支付酒店停车费。
And I bet parking was really expensive.
我敢说停车费一定很贵。
Well, it was $3.00. But still, it made me mad that they wouldn't pay the $3.00 for the parking. So I justified taking $3.00 every time I worked because I thought they should pay for parking.
嗯，要3美元。但即便如此，他们不愿支付这3美元的停车费让我很生气。所以我以他们理应支付停车费为由，证明我每次上班时拿走3美元是正当的。
You felt like an injustice had been done. And you were just righting a wrong.
你觉得自己受到了不公正待遇。你只是在纠正错误。
Yes.
是的。
And that set you on the path of crime.
这让你走上了犯罪的道路。
Yes, it did. So I discovered that if you sold a ticket from inside the roll, for example, at the beginning of the roll, like if you pulled out the little cardboard insert that started the roll of tickets and pulled the ticket out of that part of it, that number on that ticket wouldn't be part of the numbers that you would be reporting. So I would just take one ticket from the middle and sell it. So I'd just take $2.75.
是的，确实如此。所以我发现，如果你卖的是卷里的一张票，比如卷的开头，如果你把开始卷票的那块小纸板插片取出来，把票从那个部分抽出来，那张票的号码就不会出现在你汇报的号码里。所以我只是从中间拿一张票卖掉。所以我就拿走了2.75美元。
But it did require me having to pocket the $2.75 when I was in the room counting the money with all the other cashiers. So you're kind of in front of people. So you have to be able to get that money in your pocket without them seeing. So I had to learn how to do that, which actually was very easy.
但当我在房间里和其他收银员一起清点钱财时，我确实需要把那2.75美元放进兜里。所以你在别人面前。你必须能够在不被他们看见的情况下把钱放进兜里。所以我不得不学习如何做到这一点，这实际上非常容易。
How do you do it?
你是怎么做到的？
You just wait till no one's looking or just dumb things, like you cough or look the other way, and then you put $2.75 in your pocket. But then, I was working long shifts that were like eight hours. And I would get hungry. And I didn't have enough time to leave the hotel. And they didn't provide a meal. So I felt it was their responsibility to buy me lunch. So I thought, well, maybe I'll just take six more dollars' worth.
你只要等没人看的时候，或者做些蠢事，比如咳嗽一下或者看别处，然后把2.75美元放进兜里。但后来，我上的是长班，大概八个小时。我会饿。我没有足够的时间离开酒店。他们也不提供餐食。所以我认为买午餐是他们的责任。所以我心想，嗯，也许我应该多拿6美元。
OK, it's all a blur now, where it went from $6 to, oh, $500. But somehow, it just started increasing and increasing, because I started taking a little more and a little more. And then, things would happen like, oh, my car insurance would be due, and I was like $80 short.
好吧，现在一切都模糊了，钱数从6美元变成了500美元。但不知何故，它开始不断增加，因为我开始拿得越来越多。然后，会发生一些事情，比如，哦，我的车险到期了，我缺了80美元。
The thing that, looking back on it, is interesting to me is that I started getting really high from it. I would get a huge rush when I left the hotel and knew that I was safe with the money. And I can honestly say I've never really had that particular feeling of high again since I did that. And then I started doing really kind of nutty things where I would increase the danger, like I was flirting with getting caught or flirting with the danger of it.
回想起来，有趣的是，我开始从中获得极大的快感。当我离开酒店，知道那笔钱安全无虞时，我会有一种巨大的冲动。我可以诚实地说，从那以后，我再也没有真正感受到那种特殊的快感。然后我开始做一些非常疯狂的事情，我会增加危险性，比如我故意去试探被抓的边缘，或者试探犯罪的危险。
For example, I stopped parking at the hotel, and I purposely-- and this is like downtown LA, so it's a little scary and empty at night. And I would purposely park my car on the street under a tunnel, like seven blocks away with no streetlights. And then I would have like a couple hundred bucks in my pocket. And I would come out, and I would run as fast as I humanly could, for me, to my car. And I'd be drenched in sweat and as high as I've ever felt in my entire life.
例如，我不再停在酒店，而是故意——这可是洛杉矶市中心，晚上很吓人、很空旷。我故意把车停在隧道下的街上，七个街区外，没有路灯。然后我口袋里装着几百块钱。我会走出来，以我能达到的最快速度跑到车上。我会汗流浃背，感到一生中从未有过的快感。
Was it just like, I'll do the riskiest possible thing I could do?
是不是就像，“我要做我能做的最冒险的事情”？
I think it was that I got really high from feeling like I was in danger. And I kept putting myself in more danger because it was so exciting. The hairs on the back my neck would be sticking up as I would leave the hotel. And sweat would be running down my back, and I'd be shaking. But it was like getting away with it. You got away with it.
我想是因为我从感觉自己身处险境中获得了快感。我不断让自己处于更大的危险中，因为它太令人兴奋了。当我离开酒店时，我脖子后面的汗毛会竖起来。汗水顺着背往下流，我在发抖。但这就像是逃脱了惩罚。你逃脱了。
Oh, and then I would drive home. And often, I'd drive home at 2:00 or 3:00, 4:00 in the morning. And there would be, oftentimes, policemen chasing people along the road. I would drive down Sixth Avenue home. And lots of times, like most of the time, someone would be getting arrested. And it all felt very intense and exciting to me. I was in the big city, and I was part of everything. And I had this money, and I'd taken it. And I was driving down the street, and there were cops right there.
哦，然后我会开车回家。通常，我会在凌晨2点、3点或4点开车回家。路上经常有警察在追捕人。我开着车沿着第六大道回家。很多时候，大多数时候，总有人被捕。对我来说，这一切都非常激烈和令人兴奋。我在大城市，我是这一切的一部分。我有这些钱，我把它们拿走了。我开着车，警察就在那儿。
At its highest point, how much would you take a night?
在你拿得最多的时候，一晚上能拿多少？
My biggest night was $1,000.
我拿得最多的一晚是1000美元。
And when you were taking that much, how would you pocket $1,000?
当你拿这么多的时候，你是怎么把1000美元装进口袋的？
Well, that doesn't take up that much room.
嗯，那占不了多少地方。
But isn't it a big wad of $1 and $5 bills?
但那不是厚厚一叠1美元和5美元的钞票吗？
No, no, I would take the bigger bills. Oh, my god. I'm in a confessional. And you're Father [? McGrann. ?]
不，不，我会拿面额大的钞票。天哪。我是在告解室里。而你是麦克格伦神父。
But I'd know that I was getting reckless. I was taking too much. I would flirt with the moments that I could actually pocket it. I would push the envelope of when it was really-- like at the beginning, it would be $3, and I would make sure it was totally safe. And then 10 months later, it would be like $300. I remember thinking, I could pocket money while my supervisor's staring at me, and they'll never notice it. I'm that good.
但我知道我开始变得鲁莽了。我拿得太多了。我会去试探那些我真正可以把钱放进口袋的时刻。我会挑战极限，比如刚开始时，只会拿3美元，我会确保它是绝对安全的。然后10个月后，就是300美元了。我记得当时心想，我可以在主管盯着我的时候把钱装进兜里，他们永远不会注意到。我就是这么厉害。
And did you do that?
你真的那么做了吗？
I don't know if I did it that blatantly. But I definitely was doing it in front of other people where they weren't noticing it. Then I started to realize that that's exactly when you do it. It's when people would never think anyone would do that. That's when you do it. You do it right in front of their eyes. You do it while you're talking to them and you're counting out money.
我不知道我是不是做得那么明目张胆。但我肯定是在别人面前做的，他们根本没察觉。然后我开始意识到，这正是你行动的时候。当人们永远不会想到有人会这样做时。那正是你下手的时候。你就在他们眼皮底下做。你一边和他们说话，一边清点钱财。
But I justified it because I'd think, I'm not buying drugs. I'm not buying drugs. You know why other people steal? To buy drugs, which is disgusting. You know what I use this for? My rent and car insurance, and my student loan. To me, it meant that I was being honest and good with the money. It's not like I was paying some drug dealer for drugs. Like somehow, that made it OK.
但我为自己辩解，因为我会想，我不是在买毒品。我不是在买毒品。你知道别人为什么偷东西吗？为了买毒品，这太恶心了。你知道我用这些钱干什么吗？付房租、车险和助学贷款。对我来说，这意味着我在用钱上是诚实和良好的。这不像是在付钱给毒贩买毒品。不知何故，这让事情变得可以接受了。
I don't know why, but somehow, I can imagine that at the height of this, you would be somebody who would actually find herself giving away some of her stolen money to charity. Did that happen?
不知道为什么，但我总能想象，在这种状态的顶峰，你会是一个实际上发现自己会把偷来的钱捐给慈善机构的人。这发生过吗？
Oh, yeah. Well, first of all, I was going to mass every Sunday and making-- I think I was giving them $50 to $100, or something, a time. Oh, and I'm telling you, I would not miss mass one Sunday while I was doing this.
哦，是的。首先，我每个周日都去弥撒，并且捐款——我想我每次给他们50到100美元左右。哦，我告诉你，我在做这件事的时候，绝对不会缺席周日的弥撒。
It made you go to mass more, the fact that you were stealing?
因为你偷了钱，所以让你更频繁地去弥撒？
Oh, yeah. Well, because, for one, I got a high off of being able to put so much in the money container thing. I really felt good about it.
哦，是的。嗯，因为一方面，我从能够放那么多钱进那个捐款箱里获得了一种快感。我真的对此感觉很好。
That's sick.
这真病态。
It's really sick. But then, I felt-- first of all, I liked being around God. And at that time, I felt like being around God meant being in church. And I didn't really-- OK. I'm almost as if I'm talking about someone who is so far away from me, they're not me. But I didn't really think of it as a sin at the time. I thought of it as an opportunity. Almost like God had given me this opportunity. And what was I going to do, not take the opportunity?
这真的很病态。但后来，我觉得——首先，我喜欢待在上帝身边。那时，我觉得待在上帝身边意味着在教堂里。我真的没有……好吧。我说话的方式简直就像在谈论一个离我如此遥远的人，那个人不是我。但在当时，我并不认为这是一种罪。我认为这是一个机会。几乎就像上帝给了我这个机会。我能做什么，不抓住这个机会吗？
I think it was really potent for me when I was in mass because here I was with God, and I was giving money. It was like, so see, God? Here, you get your own cut. It was that we were thrown in together. It was almost like, if the only person who knows I'm doing this is God and me, we have a pretty intimate relationship going on right now. And it's very, very intimate and personal. And it's between me and God. And that made me feel, at that time, in my 22-year-old brain, like I was having a close relationship with a deity, which now I think is insane. But at the time, that all made sense to me.
我觉得当我在弥撒中时，这对我有很大的影响力，因为我正与上帝在一起，而我在捐钱。这就像是，看，上帝？这是给你的那份。这就像是我们被绑在了一起。几乎就像是，如果唯一知道我在做这件事的人是上帝和我，我们现在拥有一种非常亲密的关系。这是非常、非常私密和个人的。这是在我和上帝之间。这让我在22岁的脑子里，感觉就像我和一位神灵有着亲密的关系，我现在认为这简直是疯了。但在当时，这一切对我来说都说得通。
I have to say, you saying this, it explains this thing that, when I've seen it in fiction, when I've seen it in the Godfather movies, I have never understood and I just assumed was a literary device or something, the notion that these mobsters would commit these crimes, but then consider themselves to be Catholic guys, and go to mass and this and that. I was never able to understand. And I always thought, oh, well, that's just made up, that part.
我不得不说，你说出这些，解释了我曾在小说中、在《教父》电影中看到的东西，我从未理解过，我只是假设那是文学手法之类的，那种黑帮成员会犯下这些罪行，却认为自己是天主教徒，去参加弥撒什么的。我一直无法理解。我总是以为，哦，好吧，那部分是编出来的。
No. Oh, I understand that completely. And also, if you had gotten into a discussion with me about the Catholic church at that time, I would defend it to the end. It was almost like, that's my family you're talking about. I had much more allegiance to the church while I was doing bad things.
不。哦，我完全理解。而且，如果你在那个时候和我讨论天主教会，我会誓死捍卫它。简直就像，你谈论的是我的家人。我在做坏事时，对教会的忠诚度反而更高。
But you know what is really even more sick about my experience? I felt like God was a little bit of an accomplice with me. I didn't feel like I needed God to say it was OK. I almost felt like God was my pimp or something. I had to go pay God off. That was a weird thing I was doing in my head then.
但你知道关于我的经历还有什么更病态的吗？我觉得上帝有点像是我的同谋。我不觉得我需要上帝说这样做是对的。我几乎觉得上帝是我的皮条客什么的。我得去贿赂上帝。那是我当时脑子里做的一件奇怪的事。
And see, the big night, that's when I took the $1,000-- I can't believe I'm saying-- well, I was in Spokane for Christmas, visiting my family. And I had to get back for New Year's Eve, because New Year's Eve was the biggest night of the year for alcohol sales. That would be my biggest chance to make the most money. There would be--
看，那个大晚上，就是我拿了1000美元的那晚——我不敢相信我说了——好吧，我当时在斯波坎过圣诞节，探望家人。我必须赶在除夕前回去，因为除夕是酒精销售量最大的一年中的夜晚。那将是我赚最多钱的最佳机会。会有……
At the hotel, yeah.
在酒店，对吧。
Yeah. We'd probably count $60,000 in cash, at night, at the hotel on a New Year's Eve. So there was so much chance for the money not to be noticed. And I was in Spokane, and there was this terrible storm. And the airport closed down. And it was frozen. And no one was able to get out of the city. And they didn't even want people on the roads. And my parents said, "Oh, well, I guess you're just going to have to stay with us for New Year's Eve." And I said, "No, I have to work on New Year's Eve." And they said, "Well, call the hotel and tell them you can't make it." And I said, "No, I've got to make it. I've got to make it." And they said, "Well, but you can't make it. The roads are bad. No planes are leaving the city."
是的。我们在除夕夜那天晚上在酒店清点的现金可能达到6万美元。所以钱没被发现的机会太大了。当时我在斯波坎，发生了一场可怕的暴风雪。机场关闭了。一切都冻住了。没人能离开这座城市。他们甚至不想让人上路。我父母说，“哦，好吧，我想你只能和我们一起过除夕了。”我说，“不，我必须在除夕夜工作。”他们说，“好吧，给酒店打电话说你赶不回来。”我说，“不，我必须赶回去。我必须赶回去。”他们说，“但是你赶不回去啊。路况太差了。没有飞机能离开这座城市。”
And I got on a Greyhound bus that took, I think, 15 hours to get from Spokane to Seattle, so I could get on a plane to get back to LA, so I could work on New year's Eve. And to me, that was when I realized it was out of control. Because my feeling of having to get there-- It wasn't even about the money that much then, because I didn't even need the money that much then. It was more like, the big score's going down. I've got to get there. I've got to get there. Damn it, get me on a-- I'll walk to Seattle, but I can not miss this night. And of course, I was getting paid minimum wage. So it seemed absurd to everyone I knew that I would go to those kinds of extremes to get back, so I could go to a job where I got paid $3.50 an hour or something.
我登上一辆灰狗巴士，我想花了15个小时才从斯波坎到西雅图，这样我就能搭上一架飞机回洛杉矶，以便在除夕夜工作。对我来说，那是当我意识到一切已经失控的时候。因为我必须要赶到的感觉……那时候甚至已经不是关于钱了，因为当时我甚至不需要那么多钱。更像是，大干一场的机会要来了。我必须赶到那里。我必须赶到那里。该死，给我安排……我走也要走到西雅图，但我绝对不能错过这个夜晚。当然，我的薪水是最低工资。所以对于我认识的每一个人来说，为了去一份时薪只有3.50美元左右的工作，而不惜采取那种极端手段，似乎是很荒谬的。
Julia Sweeney is a writer and actress, who says she stopped stealing in 1984, after the whole thing started to make her sick. Then she quit her job. She hasn't stolen since. She wants you to know that she understands that stealing is wrong. Under California law, the statute of limitations for her crime, grand larceny, ran out in 1987. The CD of her one-woman show, Letting Go of God, is out this month.
朱莉娅·斯威尼是一位作家和演员，她说她在1984年当这一切开始让她感到恶心后，就停止了偷窃。然后她辞去了工作。从那以后她再也没有偷过东西。她想让你知道，她明白偷窃是不对的。根据加州法律，她所犯下的重大盗窃罪的诉讼时效已于1987年结束。她的一人秀CD《放手上帝》于本月发行。
[MUSIC - "SATAN IS REAL" BY THE LOUVIN BROTHERS]
[音乐 - 卢文兄弟的《撒旦是真的》]
Act Two, You'll Pay. Some criminals do not see themselves as basically good people getting away with something bad. Some people do not believe that God is on their side when they commit their crimes. They have a point they want to make about God, but that is not the precise point they are trying to make. We have this story from reporter Marilyn Snell about an ex-con who lives in Oakland, California.
第二幕，《你会付出代价》。有些罪犯并不认为自己是做坏事的基本的好人。有些人不认为当他们犯罪时上帝站在他们这边。他们想表达关于上帝的观点，但这并不是他们试图表达的确切观点。我们有记者玛丽琳·斯内尔带来的这个故事，关于一位住在加利福尼亚州奥克兰的前科犯。
Joe Loya spent two years in prison for grand theft auto, strong arm robbery, and bounced checks. He did another seven for bank robbery. He robbed a lot of banks.
乔·洛亚因重大汽车盗窃、武装抢劫和空头支票入狱两年。他又因银行抢劫服刑了七年。他抢了很多银行。
The official number is 24. When I was arrested, they said, "This is a bank robber who robbed 24 banks." But I know I counted once and lost count at 30 or 32.
官方数字是24。当我被捕时，他们说，“这是一个抢了24家银行的银行抢劫犯。”但我记得我曾经数过一次，在30或32时数乱了。
I was not born with a criminal mind. I don't think anybody is born with a criminal mind. I was raised in a very religious environment. My father was eventually a minister. My parents got married when they were 16. My mother was pregnant.
我天生没有犯罪头脑。我不认为任何人天生有犯罪头脑。我在一个非常虔诚的环境中长大。我父亲最终成为了一名牧师。我父母在他们16岁时就结婚了。我母亲当时怀孕了。
And my dad, real early, decided that he wanted to serve God. So he started teaching himself Greek and Hebrew. And he also learned Latin along the way, all these languages so that he could interpret the scriptures. We were a family of the text. Everything in our life, every morality, every decision had to somehow be validated by scripture. I read the Bible from cover to cover every year, because there was this program my dad had where every day, we read a little bit of the New Testament and Old Testament. And by the end of the year, the entire Bible was read.
我父亲很早就决定要侍奉上帝。所以他开始自学希腊语和希伯来语。一路上他还学了拉丁语，所有这些语言都是为了能解释经文。我们是一个以经文为准的家庭。我们生活中的一切，每一个道德规范，每一个决定，都必须以某种方式得到经文的验证。我每年都会从头到尾阅读圣经，因为我父亲有一个计划，每天我们阅读一小部分新约和旧约。到年底，整本圣经就被读完了。
My parents loved God so much. My mother was this little Sunday school teacher at the church. So that in my baby book, my mother writes when I was-- I was born August 11, 1961. And three years and four months later, on November 3, 1964, my mother wrote that I "accepted Christ as his Savior." And she wrote, [? "Faith Gurlack ?] led him to the Lord." In the baby book again, when I'm four years old, the next year, 1965, October 10, on a Sunday, she said that, "Joey feels a call to the missionary field, to tell the parents and preach in India the Gospel. He is four years old," she wrote.
我父母是如此热爱上帝。我母亲是教堂里的小主日学校老师。所以在我婴儿时期的书中，母亲写道，当我……我出生于1961年8月11日。三年零四个月后，在1964年11月3日，母亲写道我“接受了基督作为他的救主”。她写道，“费思·古拉克带领他来到主面前。”婴儿书里还写着，我四岁时，第二年，1965年10月10日，一个星期天，她说，“乔伊感到了一种去传教区的召唤，去告诉父母并在印度传讲福音。他才四岁，”她写道。
Joe's mother died when he was nine. His brother Paul was seven. Their father was suddenly alone with two young sons, not much money, and zero coping skills. It was around this time that he began to get violent with his boys.
乔的母亲在他九岁时去世了。他的弟弟保罗七岁。他们的父亲突然独自带着两个年幼的儿子，没什么钱，应对能力为零。大约就在那时，他开始对他的男孩们施暴。
My father, regular, when he would lose his temper, he would hit us severely and beat us. And then afterwards, he would cry-- like an alcoholic in a way, even though he wasn't-- but he would cry and beg our forgiveness. It would be this heavy emotional scene, where we'd cry and we'd forgive him. And we'd go to him, we love you Daddy. Don't cry. God forgives. And we'd pray. And everything would be-- supposed to be fine and dandy. And then it would happen again.
我父亲，通常情况下，当他失去理智时，他会严厉地打我们，毒打我们。事后，他会哭——就像某种酗酒者，尽管他并不酗酒——但他会哭着乞求我们的原谅。那会是一个沉重的情感场面，我们会哭着原谅他。我们会走到他身边说，我们爱你爸爸。别哭。上帝会原谅的。我们会祈祷。一切本该……应该都很好。但之后它又会发生。
When my dad finally got a church when I was about 12 years old, I couldn't understand how the people in those pews could believe in this man, when he was obviously, to me, such a fraud. And that's when I began to doubt. I began to doubt the flock, the wisdom of the flock.
当我父亲在我大约12岁时终于有了自己的教堂后，我不明白那些坐在长椅上的人怎么能相信这个人，而在我看来，他显然是个骗子。就在那时我开始怀疑了。我开始怀疑这些信徒，怀疑信徒的智慧。
I was being raised by a deceptive person. So I became sort of deceptive. And when I was in eighth grade, I was able to jimmy the lock in a cabinet that he had in his bedroom. And I would pilfer dollars out of every offering envelope that-- they kept the offering in there. And I would take my friends to go eat at Foster's Freeze. I would take a bunch of friends over there. We'd get ice cream, chips, we'd get burgers and fries and--
我是一个骗子养大的。所以我变得有点善于欺骗。当我在八年级时，我能够撬开他卧室里的一个柜子的锁。我会从每个奉献信封里偷走钱——他们把奉献放在里面。我会带我的朋友们去福斯特冰激凌店吃饭。我会带一帮朋友去那里。我们吃冰激凌、薯片，我们吃汉堡和薯条……
Courtesy of the Lord?
上帝提供的福利？
Courtesy of God. This picnic is on God. Thank you, God. Amen.
上帝提供的福利。这次野餐是上帝买单。谢谢你，上帝。阿门。
And he started dating Susie. And the same pattern began, where she thought he was a spiritual man. I despised that. I despised that he could get away with it. And what I did is, I went to this woman, and said, "Hey, listen, my dad beats us. Run far and fast as you can." She took us out to dinner one Sunday evening. And in my bravado, I said, "You know what? Next time he does it, I swear, I'm going to stab him." And I held up a steak knife.
他开始和苏茜约会。同样的模式开始了，她以为他是一个有灵性的人。我鄙视这一点。我鄙视他竟然能逃脱惩罚。我所做的是，我走到这个女人面前说，“嘿，听着，我爸爸打我们。快点跑吧。”一个周日晚上，她带我们出去吃饭。在我的虚张声势下，我说，“你知道吗？下次他再打我，我发誓，我要捅死他。”我举起了一把牛排刀。
And so a week later, within a week, he had sensed, picked up from Susie, that Susie was starting to pull away. And he assumed that maybe I had told her something. And so he called me into the kitchen. He says, "Hey, listen." He played this trick on me. He said, "Hey, I've got something to say. You told Susie that I've been a little violent with you guys and stuff. It's not a problem. I already know you told her. She told me you told her that. She was kind of concerned. So it's no big deal, but you did, didn't you? I just wanted to see if you'll admit to it." It was the first and last time I ever confessed to a crime.
一周内，他从苏茜那里察觉到，苏茜开始疏远他了。他以为可能是我告诉了她什么。于是他把我叫进厨房。他说，“嘿，听着。”他对我耍了个手段。他说，“嘿，我有话要说。你告诉苏茜我最近对你们有点暴力什么的。没问题。我已经知道你告诉她了。她告诉我你告诉她了。她很担心。所以这没什么大不了的，但你确实说了，对吧？我只是想看看你承不承认。”那是我第一次也是最后一次承认犯罪。
I see him saying that everything's fine, everything's going to be all right. And I want to believe that everything's going to be all right. I want to believe that he's going to take the high road. I want to believe in forgiveness, too. I want to believe that things can be all right. And as soon as I tell him, "Yeah, OK, I did," he throws a teapot at me, chases me around. And he proceeds to beat me, so that by that evening, in the hospital, they would X-ray me and find that I had a broken wrist, fractured elbow, and broken rib.
我看着他嘴里说着一切都好，一切都会好起来的。我想要相信一切都会好起来的。我想要相信他会改邪归正。我也想相信宽恕。我想要相信事情可以好起来。而当我告诉他，“是的，好吧，我做了，”他把一个茶壶扔向我，追赶我。他接着毒打我，以至于那天晚上，在医院里，他们给我照了X光，发现我的手腕骨折、肘部骨折和肋骨骨折。
At one point, he stops beating me. And he left the house. He went down to 7-Eleven. We didn't have a phone at the time. He went down to 7-Eleven down the block, about a mile away, calls Susie, breaks up with her, and comes back home. But it was during that time, in this state of concussion that I had-- what was later diagnosed as a massive concussion-- I'm sitting there in a daze. But I know enough to say, "Paul, go to the bathroom. Lock yourself in. Don't come out until I say."
有一次，他停止了殴打我。他离开了家。他去了7-11便利店。当时我们没有电话。他走到街区尽头，大约一英里远的地方，给苏茜打电话，和她分手，然后回家。但在那段时间里，在我那种脑震荡的状态下——后来被诊断为严重脑震荡——我坐在那里发呆。但我知道足够多的事情去说，“保罗，去浴室。把自己锁在里面。直到我说出来之前不要出来。”
I walked to the kitchen. I pulled out a knife. I went back to the bedroom. I sat on my bed. And I put the knife underneath the pillow. And I waited for him, for my father to come home. And he did. He came in the front door, walked over to my room. And he had this maniacal look on his face when he walked to my door. He looked at me. Then he looked at the other side of the room. And he saw weights there. He looked at me again. And I could tell, something's going on in that demented mind of his. And sure enough, he walks over to the weights, and he begins to disassemble them. They were cement weights that had plastic around them. And I have no clue what he's going to do. This is a new level of improvised savagery even for him.
我走到厨房。我拿出了一把刀。我回到卧室。我坐在我的床上。我把刀放在枕头下面。我等着他，等着我父亲回来。他回来了。他从前门进来，走到我的房间。当他走到我的门口时，他脸上带着这种疯狂的神情。他看着我。然后他看向房间的另一边。他看到了那里的哑铃。他又看着我。我可以看出，在他那种痴呆的脑子里正在发生什么。果然，他走向哑铃，开始拆解它们。它们是水泥做的，外面包着塑料。我一点头绪都没有他要干什么。即使对他来说，这也是一种新的临时野蛮等级。
But I wasn't about to find out what he was going to do with that, if he was going to hit me with the weights or with the bar. So what I did was, I pulled the knife out from underneath the pillow. I stood up. He said, "Put it away, put it away." And I continued to stay there. He started walking at me. And I could tell-- he started demanding that I put it down, like, "Put down the knife, put down the knife." And I lunged at him. And when I did, he put up his left arm. But I was able to stab him in the neck. And I came down hard. And I started twisting it, trying to break it off in his neck. And he screamed. And he grabbed his neck. And he said, "You killed me. You killed me." And he fell to the ground.
但我不想知道他要用那个做什么，他是不是要用哑铃还是杠铃打我。所以我所做的是，我从枕头下抽出了刀。我站了起来。他说，“把它放回去，放回去。”我继续待在那里。他开始朝我走来。我可以看出——他开始要求我把它放下，比如，“放下刀，放下刀。”我冲向他。当我这样做时，他举起了左臂。但我成功地刺中了他的脖子。我用力刺下去。我开始旋转它，试图把它断在他的脖子里。他尖叫起来。他抓住了他的脖子。他说，“你杀了我。你杀了我。”他倒在地上。
And I remember that I stood over him. And I said something. I don't quite remember the verbatim. But it was essentially, "You did this to yourself," in the sense that you brought it on yourself. Almost like a biblical thing, this is what your sin hath wrought kind of idea.
我记得我站在他上面。我说了一些话。我不完全记得原话了。但本质上是，“这是你自找的，”那种意思是你咎由自取。几乎就像一种圣经里的东西，这就是你的罪孽所酿成的后果，这种概念。
There's this great line from Auden, where he says, "I and the public know what all schoolchildren learn, those to whom evil is done do evil in return."
奥登有一句名言，“我和公众都知道学校里教的东西，那些遭受邪恶的人会反过来作恶。”
This is the man I feared the most in the world. After him was God. And when I knocked him off his pedestal, there was nobody who could replace him. Not the police, not teachers, not politicians, nothing. The only person I had to fear after I knocked my dad off was the heavens. And that was God. And I couldn't see him. So that meant that I had primacy of my life on this planet. I became my own God here. I did not fear authority anymore.
这是我这辈子最害怕的人。在他之后是上帝。当我把他从神坛上拉下来时，再也没有人能取代他。警察不行，老师不行，政客也不行，什么都不行。在我把我爸从神坛上拉下来后，唯一我必须害怕的人就是天堂。那就是上帝。我看不见他。这意味着我在这个星球上的生活中拥有至高无上的权力。我成了我自己的上帝。我不再害怕权威了。
Joe's father survived the stabbing, but lost his sons to foster care for several months. After Joe graduated from high school, he attended Bible college for a semester, but dropped out. He didn't want to work, so he supported himself by stealing from his friends. After a while, he moved on to bigger targets. He stole cars, passed fraudulent checks, and finally began robbing banks. In 1988, after being released from a two-year prison sentence, he went on a 14-month-long bank robbing spree.
乔的父亲在刺伤事件中幸存下来，但他的儿子们被寄养了几个月。乔高中毕业后，在圣经学院上了一个学期，但退学了。他不想工作，所以他靠偷朋友的东西维持生活。过了一段时间，他转移到更大的目标。他偷车，使用伪造支票，并最终开始抢劫银行。1988年，在两年刑期后获释，他开始了长达14个月的银行抢劫狂潮。
Well, I'd wake up and say, "I don't know what I want to do today. I just know I want to look good, and I want to go spend a lot of money. And I want to have fun. Maybe I want to spend $10,000 today. I want to go to Vegas. I want to fly all my friends someplace, buy them all nice clothes, and eat. That's $10,000 I'm going to lose. Maybe I should go rob a bank or two tomorrow."
嗯，我会醒来说，“我不知道今天想做什么。我只知道我想看起来不错，我想去花一大笔钱。我想玩得开心。也许我今天想花1万美元。我想去拉斯维加斯。我想带我所有的朋友去某个地方，给他们买漂亮的衣服，吃东西。那是1万美元，我会花掉的。也许明天我应该去抢一两家银行。”
So that was your notion of living from check to check?
这就是你所谓的月光族想法？
My idea of living check to check was, I have $40,000 here. That means it's going to be gone in three months. That was my idea, yeah.
我对月光族的想法是，我有4万美元在这里。这意味着三个月内就会花光。这就是我的想法，是的。
So where would you keep your money?
那你把钱放在哪里？
Always under my bed in a gym bag. $40,000 of smelly dough. Money is very smelly.
总是放在床下的一个健身包里。4万美元臭气熏天的钞票。钱是非常臭的。
I was going to ask you this. Did you smell the money?
我正要问你这个。你闻过钱吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Why?
为什么？
You can't not smell the money. Because you're intrigued by the fact that money is putrid. It's like-- I don't want to say it's disgusting-- It's like you smell the money, and you'll be like, "Is that you?" And you put your face in it. And you're like, "Oh, yeah, it is you. You stink." It's disgusting.
你不可能不闻钱。因为你对钱是腐臭的事实感到好奇。这就像——我不想说它恶心——就像你闻钱，你会想，“是你吗？”你把脸凑上去。然后你会想，“哦，是的，就是你。你真臭。”它很恶心。
On my way to a bank, I'd have this conversation with my body, where my body would start to rebel naturally because it was frightened. It knew I was putting itself into harm's way. I always had a gun. So I knew that there was a possibility of using the gun. My stomach would get knotted. I'd feel like I had the runs. I would start to shake. I'd violently shake sometimes. My hands almost want to bounce off the steering wheel.
在去银行的路上，我会和我的身体进行这种对话，我的身体会自然地开始反抗，因为它害怕。它知道我正让它置身于危险之中。我总是带着枪。所以我知道有可能使用那把枪。我的胃会打结。我感觉就像拉肚子。我会开始颤抖。有时我猛烈地颤抖。我的双手几乎想从方向盘上弹开。
If that couldn't stop me, then this intense wave of fatigue would come over me. And if I pulled over to the side of the road and I wanted to, I'm sure I could've just gone to sleep right away. My body just wanted to shut down. And when I pushed through that with my will, then this incredible calm would come over me. And that's when I was in control.
如果这不能阻止我，那么这股强烈的疲劳感会袭来。如果我靠边停车，我想的话，我肯定立刻就能睡着。我的身体只想关机。当我用意志力冲破这一点时，一种不可思议的平静就会袭来。那时我才处于控制之中。
I would walk in there, wait in line, get up to a teller and lean forward, speak very clearly but low. And I would tell them that we have a bomb, I have a gun, and this is a bank robbery. Give me the money now. And even though it was only me, I wanted to give the impression that, listen, the all-seeing eye of horrors is out there, kind of thing. There's somebody behind me who sees you and sees me, and I have backup. And I came with that kind of confidence.
我会走进去，排队，走到柜员面前身体前倾，声音很清晰但很低。我会告诉他们我们有炸弹，我有枪，这是一场银行抢劫。现在把钱给我。虽然只有我一个人，但我想要给人一种印象，听着，恐怖的全知之眼就在外面，那种感觉。我后面有人看着你和看着我，而且我有支援。我就带着那种自信来的。
Asian women and black women were the most difficult to rob. What I thought about Asian women was, these are women who just came over from Vietnam. And they saw bodies strewn all over the village. They are not afraid of a little guy like me coming up without a weapon. I thought that.
亚洲女性和黑人女性是最难抢的。关于亚洲女性，我想的是，这些女性刚刚从越南过来。她们在村子里见过到处都是尸体。她们并不害怕我这种没武器冲上去的小个子。我是这样想的。
And then, with the black women, I felt like, these are women who talk to black men a certain way. There is this certain aggression between them, this, "You don't have a gun. What are you going to do, reach across here and slap me? Uh-uh. I don't think so." I kind of got that feeling like, you're not going to do anything. And that's when I had to-- it took too much work. I had to pretend like I was ready-- I put my hand real fiercely on the counter. And I'd say, "I'm coming. Don't make me come over. I'll shoot you." It was just way too much work.
然后，对于黑人女性，我觉得，这些女性和黑人男性说话的方式不一样。她们之间有一种特定的攻击性，那种，“你没枪。你打算怎么办，伸手过来打我吗？呃呃。我不这么认为。”我有一种感觉，就像，你什么也做不了。那时我不得不——这太费劲了。我不得不装作我已经准备好了——我凶狠地把手按在柜台上。然后我会说，“我来了。别逼我过去。我会开枪打死你的。”这真是太费劲了。
Who I found were the easiest to rob were these middle class white women who looked like their daughter and son just went off to college, and now they finally get to go to work again. And they decided to work from 1:00 to 3:00 every day at the bank, get a little money in, so they could buy their stuff for ceramics or something. They would always greet me very cheerfully. And they were the easiest ones to rob. In fact, a couple times, I was embarrassed at the ease. I'd say, "This is a robbery," to one woman. And she just looked down, opened the drawer, and started giving me the big bills first. I didn't have to finish my spiel. And I almost felt like, "Hey lady, you do this any faster, they're going to think we were in cahoots."
我发现最容易抢的是那些中产阶级白人女性，她们看起来就像她们的女儿和儿子刚去上大学，现在她们终于可以再次去上班了。她们决定每天下午1点到3点在银行工作，赚点钱，这样她们就可以买陶瓷材料之类的东西。她们总是非常愉快地迎接我。她们是最容易抢的。事实上，有几次，我甚至因为太容易而感到尴尬。我对一个女人说，“这是一场抢劫。”她只是低头，打开抽屉，开始先给我大面额的钞票。我甚至都不必说完我的话。我几乎感觉像是，“嘿女士，你再做快点，他们会以为我们是一伙的。”
To the tellers, what I felt I was introducing them to was the same notion of hazard that I had known as a child, which is, I was going through life fine. Everything was going good for me. And all of a sudden, my mother's dead. Whoa, what happened here? All of a sudden, my dad can't deal with his anger, and he's beating us. Whoa, what's happening here?
对于柜员们，我觉得我是在向她们介绍和我儿时所知的危险相同的概念，那就是，我过得很好。一切对我来说都很顺利。突然之间，我母亲死了。哇，这里发生了什么？突然之间，我父亲无法处理他的愤怒，他在殴打我们。哇，这里发生了什么？
Life is not what we think it is. And there are these violent intersections where, when your life intersects with hazard or contingency, it's something profound. And that's what I felt I was introducing them to. It's like, now you know. Now I can live off of your terror. It's what I did to my father when I stabbed him and I heard him crying. I loved that. I said, "Now you know how I feel."
生活并不是我们想的那样。有这些暴力的交集，当你的生活与危险或偶然性交集时，这是一件深刻的事情。这就是我感觉我是在向她们介绍的东西。就像，现在你知道了。现在我可以靠你们的恐惧生活了。这就是我捅我父亲时，听到他哭泣时我所做的。我喜欢那样。我说，“现在你知道我的感受了。”
Violence helped me recover a sense of my lost self. I could look at somebody else and say, "Ha ha, you see. Now you're a fool. You thought you could just go through life and everything was going to be nice if you behaved a certain way. And look at, now you've met me. And look at how frightened you are. And now look at how frightened you're going to be forever. And this experience is not-- you're never going to recover from it." It was validating. It made me feel like, this is the world I know. This is the way experience really is. And now all I'm doing is educating people.
暴力帮助我恢复了一种丢失的自我感。我可以看着别人说，“哈哈，你看到了。现在你是个傻瓜了。你以为你只要过日子，如果你表现得好，一切都会很好。看看，现在你遇到我了。看看你现在有多恐惧。现在看看你以后将永远有多恐惧。这种经历不是——你永远无法从中恢复过来。”这让人确认。它让我觉得，这就是我所知道的世界。这就是现实经历的样子。现在我所做的只是在教育人们。
Joe Loya was released from prison in 1997. He's gone through big changes since his days as a bank robber. Now he's an editor at Pacific News Service . He's married. At the wedding ceremony, Joe's father, who he's reconciled with, recited from the book of Corinthians, chapter 13, "Love is patient. Love is kind. Love is not envious or boastful or arrogant or rude. It does not insist on its own way. It is not irritable or resentful. It does not rejoice in wrongdoing."
乔·洛亚于1997年从监狱获释。自从他做银行抢劫犯的日子以来，他经历了大变样。现在他是《太平洋新闻服务》的编辑。他结婚了。在婚礼仪式上，乔已经和解的父亲朗读了《哥林多前书》第13章，“爱是恒久忍耐，又有恩慈。爱是不嫉妒，不自夸，不张狂，不做害羞的事，不求自己的益处，不轻易发怒，不计算人的恶，不喜欢不义。”
Marilyn Snell is a reporter in San Francisco. Joe Loya has published a memoir called The Man Who Outgrew His Prison Cell: Confessions of a Bank Robber.
玛丽琳·斯内尔是旧金山的一名记者。乔·洛亚出版了一本回忆录，名为《超越监狱牢房的男人：银行抢劫犯的忏悔录》。
Coming up, they took Europe back from the Nazis. They raised the flag at Iwo Jima. And they'll be damned if they're going to spend their golden years sitting around playing Pinochle. Sticky fingers, wrinkled hands. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，他们从纳粹手中夺回了欧洲。他们在硫磺岛升起了国旗。如果让他们在打打扑克中度过晚年，他们会气得要死。贪婪的手，皱纹的手。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目，稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of people to take a whack at that theme with documentaries, interviews, performances, found tape, found documents, anything we can think of. Today's program, The Allure of Crime, how people express themselves and their personalities through the way they steal. Let us begin the second half of our show as we began the first, with a review of criminal activity from around the nation, in this case, from Colorado, Washington state, and Georgia.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种各样的人通过纪录片、采访、表演、发现的录音带、发现的文档、任何我们能想到的东西来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，《犯罪的诱惑》，人们如何通过他们偷窃的方式来表达自己和他们的个性。让我们像开始上半场一样开始节目的下半场，回顾全国各地的犯罪活动，在这种情况下，来自科罗拉多州、华盛顿州和乔治亚州。
Crime blotter. The Athens Daily News, Athens, Georgia. A recent immigrant to Athens, whom police initially suspected of driving under the influence Wednesday, turned out to be merely unfamiliar with traffic laws, according to the Athens-Clarke county police report. A police officer spotted the man, 24, driving a white Pontiac Grand Prix on the Atlanta highway late Wednesday night, having trouble staying in one lane. The officer turned on his lights and siren, and pursued the man, who did not stop, according to the report.
犯罪记录。雅典《每日新闻》，乔治亚州雅典。据雅典-克拉克县警察报告，一名最近移民到雅典的男子，最初被警察怀疑酒后驾车，结果只是不熟悉交通法规。一名警察在周三深夜在亚特兰大高速公路上发现该名24岁的男子驾驶一辆白色庞蒂亚克大奖赛，在保持车道上遇到困难。据报道，该警察打开车灯和警笛，追逐该男子，但他没有停下来。
Police finally stopped the man on Epps Bridge Road, beside the Lowe's hardware store. The man explained to officers in broken English that he came to the US six months ago and had started driving a month ago. Officers noticed a card with written instructions on driving, explaining to put the key in the ignition, press the accelerator, and other basics, taped to the dashboard of the man's Pontiac. According to the report, the man told officers he did not know the light and siren of a police car signified that he was supposed to stop. The man was ticketed and released.
警方最终在洛斯硬件商店旁边的埃普斯桥路上拦下了该男子。该男子用破碎的英语向警察解释说，他六个月前来到美国，一个月前才开始开车。警察注意到庞蒂亚克的仪表盘上贴着一张写有驾驶说明的卡片，解释如何将钥匙插入点火装置、踩油门以及其他基本知识。据报告，该男子告诉警察，他不知道警车的灯和警笛意味着他应该停下来。该男子被罚款并获释。
Crime blotter. The Pueblo Chieftain , Pueblo, Colorado. Mike Baca 37, was eating at Phil's Diner, 2225 Lake Avenue, about 2:30 AM Thursday, when he told police he asked William Baros for a cigarette. And Baros became enraged. "You want a cigarette?" Baros reportedly said. "What kind of sucker do you think I am?" Baca said Baros then started to call him names and threw two sugar dispensers at him. They shattered when they hit a wall. Baros also threw a salt and pepper shaker set and an ashtray, according to police reports. Baros then tried to hit Baca with a chair. Baros was arrested and faces charges of third degree assault and criminal mischief.
犯罪记录。《普韦布洛酋长报》，科罗拉多州普韦布洛。37岁的迈克·巴卡于周四凌晨2点30分左右在湖大道2225号的菲尔餐厅用餐时，告诉警方他向威廉·巴罗斯要了一根烟。结果巴罗斯勃然大怒。“你想要一根烟？”巴罗斯据称说道。“你以为我是什么样的大傻瓜？”巴卡说巴罗斯随后开始骂他，并向他扔了两个糖果瓶。它们撞到墙上时粉碎了。据警方报告，巴罗斯还扔了一个盐和胡椒粉瓶套装和一个烟灰缸。然后巴罗斯试图用椅子打巴卡。巴罗斯被捕，面临三级袭击和刑事破坏罪的指控。
Crime blotter. The Athens Daily News , Athens, Georgia. Two juveniles mugged the Easter bunny at Georgia Square recently as he left the stage for a break. "They came up to me, gave me a hug, and knocked my head back," said the battered bunny, a 19-year-old drama student at the University of Georgia. "From what I was told, they were trying to take off the head," the bunny said. "I experienced disorientation and a severe headache, resulting in a contusion." Police took a dim view of the incident. They rounded up two suspects, ages 12 and 13, and booked them on charges of simple battery. "It's a sad day when the Easter bunny can't appear in public without a security escort," said police sergeant [? Mike Brenner ?].
犯罪记录。雅典《每日新闻》，乔治亚州雅典。两名少年最近在乔治亚广场抢劫了复活节兔子，当时他正离开舞台休息。“他们走到我身边，拥抱了我，然后把我的头往后推，”这位受虐待的兔子，一名佐治亚大学的19岁戏剧学生说。“据我所知，他们是想把头套摘下来，”兔子说。“我经历了迷失方向和剧烈头痛，导致了挫伤。”警方对这一事件持严肃态度。他们逮捕了两名分别为12岁和13岁的嫌疑人，并以简单殴打罪对他们立案。“这是悲哀的一天，复活节兔子如果没有安全护送就不能出现在公共场合，”警长迈克·布伦纳说。
Crime blotter reports written by local reporters John Bauer, Juan Espinosa, Ben Deck, Stephen Gurr, and Joan Stroer. Thanks also to Gail Mann and Duncan Frazier, Jim Thompson and Greg Martin. Our police blotter was read by actor Matt Malloy, who recently played a cop in the movie Cookie's Fortune and another authority figure, the vice principal, in the movie Election.
犯罪记录报告由当地记者约翰·鲍尔、胡安·埃斯皮诺萨、本·戴克、斯蒂芬·格尔和琼·斯特罗尔撰写。也感谢盖尔·曼和邓肯·弗雷泽、吉姆·汤普森和格雷格·马丁。我们的犯罪记录由演员马特·马洛伊朗读，他最近在电影《饼干的财富》中扮演警察，并在电影《选举》中扮演另一个权威人物，副校长。
Act Three, Grandma Takes a Fall. Let's start this act with something that a 19-year-old shoplifter from New York State said in an interview for today's show.
第三幕，《祖母跌倒了》。让我们以一名来自纽约州的19岁入店行窃者在为今天节目做的采访中所说的话开始这一幕。
I really don't think-- I can't imagine myself at 28 or 30, or definitely not like 40 or like 60 years old, and stealing something, just because I think I'll be at a place in my life where I'll be maybe more comfortable with the boredom. I won't be as restless. I'm just a really restless person.
我真的不认为——我无法想象自己在28岁或30岁，或者肯定不是像40岁或60岁时偷东西，只是因为我认为我会在我生活中的某个位置，也许更能适应无聊。我不会那么烦躁。我只是一个非常烦躁的人。
Well, meet Stanley Rosenthal.
好吧，认识一下斯坦利·罗森塔尔。
I want to tell you, this golden years is not that great. Ask, "Tell me." I'll tell you about it. When you're a senior, every day is something else. You get an ear ache, you go to sleep, it's fine, you'll get up with a toothache. When the toothache disappears, the next day, you get up with a toe ache, or the arthritis gets to you. These are things that happen to you as a senior. And sometimes, people get aggravated with the world. And that's why they go out and steal. They're just pissed off. They don't care. "What the heck? Why did God do this to me?" Why can't-- They'll get revenge. It's revenge. It's a way of getting revenge.
我想告诉你，这黄金岁月并没有那么好。问，“告诉我。”我会告诉你的。当你是一名长者时，每一天都是别的东西。你耳疼，你去睡觉，没问题，你会起床带着牙疼。当牙疼消失时，第二天，你起床带着脚趾疼，或者关节炎缠上你了。这些是作为长者会发生在你身上的事情。有时，人们会对世界感到恼火。这就是为什么他们出去偷窃。他们只是气坏了。他们不在乎。“搞什么鬼？为什么上帝要这样对我？”为什么不能——他们会报复。这是报复。这是一种报复的方式。
Stanley Rosenthal runs a program in Broward County, Florida. There are programs like it all over Florida, and in fact, all over the country. If you're over 60 and arrested for shoplifting in Broward County, the judge sends your case to Stanley. Stanley sees an average of 600 senior citizens a year. He spoke with Jeanne Finley and Doug DuBois.
斯坦利·罗森塔尔在佛罗里达州布劳沃德县经营一个项目。佛罗里达各地都有这样的项目，实际上，全国各地都有。如果你超过60岁并在布劳沃德县因入店行窃被捕，法官会把你的案子送到斯坦利那里。斯坦利平均每年处理600名老年公民。他与珍妮·芬利和道格·杜波依斯进行了交谈。
Nobody knows how much theft is committed each year by senior citizens. One study found that seniors comprised 15% of people apprehended for shoplifting. Seniors, of course, tend to be poorer than other Americans. But counselors who work with senior shoplifters say that many of them are not stealing out of need. About half of senior shoplifters, they say, have stolen all their lives. Stanley sends offenders to do community service. He does a healthy business.
没人知道老年公民每年犯下多少盗窃罪。一项研究发现，老年人占被捕的入店行窃者人数的15%。当然，老年人往往比其他美国人更穷。但与老年入店行窃者工作的辅导员说，他们中许多人偷窃并不是因为需要。他们说，大约一半的老年入店行窃者一生都在偷东西。斯坦利派遣罪犯做社区服务。他做的业务很健康。
[TELEPHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Stan Rosenthal, can I help you? Listen, Jane. I've got you. You're in the program. Listen, you do something. You've got to go into your church or something and do 20 hours of community service-- Yeah, well, yes and send a-- I'm going to tell you, be careful, be good. Because we get arrested the next time, honey, you're coming with your pajamas and your toothbrush, because you're going to go to jail. So I'm just telling you, that's what. A second time, they don't stand for second offenders. OK, dear? All right, give me a call in a couple weeks. Bye-bye.
斯坦·罗森塔尔，我能帮你吗？听着，简。我明白了。你在计划里。听着，你做点什么。你得去你的教堂或者什么地方做20小时的社区服务——嗯，是的，是的，发一个——我会告诉你，小心点，表现好点。因为我们下次如果被捕，亲爱的，你得带着睡衣和牙刷来，因为你要去坐牢了。所以我只是告诉你，就是这样。第二次，他们不会容忍再犯。好吗，亲爱的？好的，几周后再给我打电话。再见。
When they first come in, when they come in here, their head down to the floor. They're miserable. They have no hope. They're terribly concerned that the kids, their grandchildren, are going to find out. And then I encourage them. I tell them what the program is all-- "Nobody's going to know. Keep your mouth shut. Don't tell anybody. The worst thing to do is tell your friends. Your sympathy, looking for sympathy. First thing you know, your friend is telling 68 people. And the first thing you know, 900 people know about you. You go over to a restaurant, say, 'Oh, you got arrested for shoplifting the other day, didn't you?'" This way, I tell them, "Don't even tell your mother. Don't tell your kids. Don't tell anybody. That's right. Keep your mouth shut. Never open up your mouth because people stink."
当他们第一次进来时，当他们来到这里时，他们头低着。他们很痛苦。他们毫无希望。他们非常担心孩子们，他们的孙子们，会发现。然后我鼓励他们。我告诉他们这个计划是什么——“没人会知道。闭上你的嘴。别告诉任何人。最糟糕的事情是告诉你的朋友。寻找同情，寻找同情。第一个你知道的，你的朋友正在告诉68个人。第一个你知道的，900个人知道你的事。你去一家餐馆，说，‘哦，你前几天因为入店行窃被捕了，是吧？’”这样，我告诉他们，“连你母亲都别告诉。别告诉你的孩子们。别告诉任何人。那是对的。闭上你的嘴。永远别张开你的嘴，因为人很臭。”
The place was very crowded because they had a sale on. And when I went to the door, I started to go out the door, and then a woman came and grabbed my arm, and took me by the elbow, and turned me around, and began to take me into the store again. And she said I had taken something that wasn't mine and without paying for it. And I said, no I hadn't.
那个地方非常拥挤，因为他们在促销。当我走到门口时，我开始要出门，然后一个女人过来抓住了我的胳膊，抓住我的肘部，把我转过来，开始带我重新进店。她说我拿了不属于我的东西，还没付钱。我说，不，我没有。
This woman asks that we not give her name over the radio because, you know, people stink. We can say that she lives in another big state that is far from Florida. She talked with Jeanne Finley.
这个女人要求我们在广播中不要提她的名字，因为，你知道，人很臭。我们可以说她住在远离佛罗里达的另一个大州。她与珍妮·芬利进行了交谈。
Oh, I wanted to run away. I couldn't believe it. I tried to run away, as a matter of fact. But she had such a tight hold on my arm, she steered me back into the store. And it was very embarrassing with all the people watching. And I felt terrible. I thought I was going to have a heart attack. I thought I was going to faint. And I was so upset that when I got into the little room, they gave me a glass of water to drink because I was so upset.
哦，我想逃跑。我简直不敢相信。事实上，我试过逃跑。但她抓着我的胳膊太紧了，她把我导回了店里。所有看着的人让我非常尴尬。我感觉糟糕透了。我想我可能会心脏病发作。我想我可能会晕倒。我太难过了，当我进入那个小房间时，他们给了我一杯水喝，因为我太难过了。
And when the police came, what happened?
警察来的时候，发生了什么？
When the police came, I had to empty my pocketbook. And I had to show them what I had in it. And they immediately pounced on the aspirin and said that this was what I had stolen and taken away without paying for it. And I said, "No." And finally, I had to admit that I had done it. I offered to pay for the aspirin, but they said, no, it doesn't work that way, that I had taken it. And so I had to suffer from the consequences of having taken the aspirin.
警察来的时候，我不得不清空我的钱包。我不得不给他们看我钱包里有什么。他们立刻扑向阿司匹林，说这就是我偷的，没付钱就拿走的。我说，“不。”最终，我不得不承认是我干的。我主动提出支付阿司匹林的钱，但他们说，不，不是那样的，因为我拿了它。所以我不得不遭受拿走阿司匹林的后果。
And I said, "What's going to happen to me now?" And they said, "Well, you have a choice. You can go to jail, or you can take a course to stop you from shoplifting." It was a program specifically for senior shoplifters. And we were supposed to look into ourselves and find out what made us shoplift.
我说，“我现在会怎么样？”他们说，“嗯，你可以选择。你可以去坐牢，或者你可以参加一个课程来阻止你入店行窃。”这是一个专门针对老年入店行窃者的项目。我们本应反思自己，找出是什么让我们入店行窃。
What did you come up with? What did you learn from it?
你得出了什么结论？你从中学到了什么？
Well, I learned that I enjoyed the shoplifting beforehand. But I don't know why. I didn't really learn that much from the sessions. I always enjoyed shoplifting. I always enjoyed taking things. But we were told that that wasn't the way we should feel, that we should feel guilty and ashamed of what we had done.
嗯，我学到的是我以前喜欢入店行窃。但我不知道为什么。我并没有从这些课程中学到那么多。我一直喜欢入店行窃。我一直喜欢拿东西。但我们被告知那不应该是我们的感受，我们应该为所作所为感到内疚和羞耻。
This is a drugstore similar to the one where I was caught shoplifting. But I can't go back to that one, because they don't allow you to go in once you've been caught shoplifting. Well, this is the candy aisle. But I don't ever go down the candy aisle. It's too open and too many people in this area. I like to go down an aisle where there are not many people.
这是一个药店，类似于我因入店行窃被抓的那个。但我不能回到那个，因为一旦你被抓到入店行窃，他们就不让你进去了。嗯，这是糖果过道。但我从不去糖果过道。它太公开了，这个区域人太多了。我喜欢去人不多的一条过道。
I've shoplifted most of my life. I started when I was quite young. And it was a way of getting back at my parents because they were so strict to me. And I would take things. They didn't allow me to have candy, so I took candy. They didn't allow me to wear my hair in a fancy style, so I took bobby pins. They didn't allow me to dress in a certain way. I couldn't have earrings. It was so easy to just go to the store, and whatever I wanted, I would just slip into a bag that I had with me. And then it began to be a question of I felt I could pull something off that other people couldn't do. And I felt very good about that. And then I began to be happy that I could get something for nothing. And that was great.
我大半辈子都在入店行窃。我很小的时候就开始了。这是反抗我父母的一种方式，因为他们对我太严厉了。我会拿东西。他们不允许我吃糖果，所以我就拿糖果。他们不允许我留时髦的发型，所以我拿发夹。他们不允许我穿某种衣服。我不能戴耳环。只要去商店，无论我想要什么，我都会悄悄地放进我随身带的包里，这太容易了。然后它开始变成一个问题，我觉得我能做成别人做不到的事。我对此感觉非常好。然后我开始感到高兴，因为我能不劳而获。那真是太好了。
I didn't shoplift so much when my children were young, because I was busy and very involved with the family and getting meals and things like that. But once in a while, when I would be in the store after the children were in school and everything, I would go and pick up a thing or two. But it was much less frequent when I had my children.
我的孩子们还小的时候，我没有那么频繁地入店行窃，因为我很忙，而且非常专注于家庭，做饭什么的。但偶尔，当孩子们在学校，一切都安顿好后，我会去店里拿一两样东西。但有孩子的时候次数少多了。
Did your husband or your children know?
你的丈夫或孩子们知道吗？
Oh, they never knew. I wouldn't have told them for anything. I would be afraid to tell them.
哦，他们永远不知道。我无论如何都不会告诉他们。我会害怕告诉他们。
Have you told anybody about the fact that you were caught recently?
你有没有告诉任何人你最近被抓的事实？
I haven't told anybody but you. And you said you wouldn't tell anybody.
除了你，我谁也没告诉。你说过你不会告诉任何人的。
I held the basket on my arm just like this. And then I had my purse on my other shoulder. And as I went down the aisle, I had stopped and looked around to make sure nobody was watching me. But there are so many mirrors in this store. There are mirrors over there, there are mirrors over there. And I imagine there are a lot of TV cameras that I can't even see.
我像这样拿着篮子在胳膊上。然后我的钱包在我的另一个肩膀上。当我走过过道时，我停下来四处看了看，确保没人盯着我。但这个店里有太多的镜子。那边有镜子，那边有镜子。而且我想还有很多我甚至看不见的电视摄像头。
Well, actually, I shoplift whenever the mood strikes me, whenever I feel sad or depressed in any way. I can't tell you exactly how many times, because I guess I don't keep that careful track. But I would guess at least once a month, if not more often. And I do it because it gives me such a lift to be out among people and to be pulling this off on them.
嗯，实际上，只要心情来了，只要我感到悲伤或沮丧，我就会入店行窃。我不能告诉你确切的次数，因为我想我没有那么仔细地跟踪。但我猜至少一个月一次，如果不是更频繁的话。我这样做是因为能在人中穿梭，并把这种事瞒天过海，这给了我很大的鼓舞。
You know, when my husband died, I got very lonely. And I didn't like to be so lonely. I wanted to get out and do things. But I couldn't get out because I didn't know anybody. See, he worked and I didn't. And he went out and had a lot of friends. And I didn't have many friends because I stayed home. Only the neighbors. And sometimes, the neighbors were younger than I was, and they were all busy and involved. And after my children grew up, I didn't have much chance to meet people.
你知道，我丈夫去世时，我很孤独。我不喜欢那么孤独。我想出去做点事情。但我出不去，因为我不认识任何人。你看，他工作，我不工作。他出去有很多朋友。我没有多少朋友，因为我呆在家里。只有邻居。有时，邻居比我年轻，他们都很忙。孩子们长大后，我没什么机会认识人。
I feel quite lonely as a senior because my children moved away. And then, they weren't nearby. And they were all involved in their own doings and lives. And I felt very sad and lonely. And when I get out and go to the store and go to the sales and look at the merchandise, it gives me a great deal of happiness to do this.
作为一名长者，我感到相当孤独，因为我的孩子们搬走了。然后，他们不在附近。他们都沉浸在自己的事务和生活中。我感到非常悲伤和孤独。当我出去逛商店，看看促销活动，看看商品时，这样做给了我很大的快乐。
Well, I held my purse in this manner and opened it up. And I was looking things over, taking them off the shelf and looking them over. And I got my Kleenex out of my purse. And I would, a-choo. And then, I took the Kleenex to wipe my nose and slipped the aspirin in my purse so they couldn't see it.
嗯，我以这种方式拿着我的钱包打开了它。我在看东西，把它们从架子上拿下来看。我从钱包里拿出纸巾。然后，我，阿嚏。然后，我用纸巾擦了擦鼻子，把阿司匹林塞进我的钱包，这样他们就看不到了。
That's the trouble with those senior centers. They're all seniors, and they've all got the same problems and the same difficulties. I like to be out shoplifting or going to the market or going to the store and looking at the sales and doing things like that, being among all types of people, all ages and all kinds.
那些老年中心就是有这个问题。他们都是长者，都有同样的问题和困难。我喜欢出去入店行窃，或者去市场，或者去商店看促销活动，做这些事情，置身于各种类型的人中间，各种年龄和各种各样的人。
And in the senior center, another thing. All they do is to play bridge. And I don't know how to play bridge. I started taking lessons. But the lessons were kind of difficult. And you had to keep your attention on them, and you had to keep playing. And I didn't always want to go to the senior center, because I have arthritis, and my arthritis began to hurt. And I didn't want to go there and play bridge with a bunch of people that I didn't know very well. It was much more fun to go shoplifting.
而且在老年中心，还有一件事。他们所做的就是打桥牌。而我不知道怎么打桥牌。我开始上课。但课程有点难。你得把注意力集中在上面，你得不停地玩。而且我并不总是想去老年中心，因为我有关节炎，我的关节炎开始疼了。我不想去那里和一群我不熟悉的人玩桥牌。去入店行窃有趣多了。
I need to get some bandages today. But I'm not sure I want to do it here. I feel very open and exposed here.
我今天需要买点绷带。但我不知道我是否想在这里买。在这里我感觉非常公开和暴露。
When I was young, I took things that a young girl would take. I took things like makeup and things like that, that would make me prettier and more attractive to other people. But as I grew older, I began to take things that I needed more, like the aspirin. I needed the aspirin. And I began to take that sort of thing, rather than the makeup and the things like that.
我年轻的时候，拿的是年轻女孩会拿的东西。我拿像化妆品之类的东西，能让我看起来更漂亮，对别人更有吸引力。但随着年龄增长，我开始拿我更需要的东西，比如阿司匹林。我需要阿司匹林。我开始拿那种东西，而不是化妆品之类的。
And did you ever try to stop?
你有没有试过停止？
Oh, I have tried. But you can't stop something that-- I guess it's kind of like drinking. You can't stop drinking because you enjoy it. Well, I couldn't stop shoplifting because I enjoy it.
哦，我试过。但你不能停止那种——我猜这有点像喝酒。你不能停止喝酒，因为你喜欢它。嗯，我不能停止入店行窃，因为我喜欢它。
Why do you think the program is not effective? Was it not effective because the things that make you want to shoplift, the program couldn't change?
你认为为什么这个项目无效？是因为让你想入店行窃的东西，这个项目无法改变吗？
Yes, that's really why. I couldn't get my children to come and be with me more. I couldn't get other people to come. My arthritis keeps hurting, and nobody seems to be able to stop that from hurting. So I wanted something that would take my mind off my hurt. And I could shoplift and be very clever doing that. And it would take my mind off my pain.
是的，确实是这样。我无法让我的孩子们多来看看我。我也无法让其他人过来。我的关节炎一直疼，似乎没人能阻止它疼。所以我想要一些能让我不去想疼痛的东西。我可以入店行窃，并且在做这件事时非常聪明。它会让我不去想我的痛苦。
In the program in your senior center, did you make friends with any of the other people in the class?
在你们老年中心的那个项目中，你和班里的其他人成为朋友了吗？
You mean when I was in the--
你是说当我在——
In the program.
在项目中。
--recovery program?
——康复项目中？
Yeah.
是的。
No, I didn't. Who wants to get friendly with people who are thieves?
不，没有。谁想和一群小偷交朋友？
But you're not a thief?
但你不是小偷？
Well, I don't consider myself a thief. I guess, technically, I am.
嗯，我不认为自己是小偷。我想，从技术上讲，我是。
But you don't feel like a thief?
但你不觉得自己像个小偷？
No, I don't feel like a thief. I feel as though I deserve what I get. I've worked hard all my life. And I deserve to have a little something extra. But I guess society doesn't look at it that way.
不，我不觉得自己像个小偷。我觉得我理应得到我所得到的。我一辈子努力工作。我理应得到多一点额外的东西。但我想社会并不这样看。
That interview by Jeanne Finley, a documentary filmmaker in New York.
那是纽约纪录片制作人珍妮·芬利做的采访。
Our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors for this show, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann, Seth Lind, and Thea Chaloner. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Musical help today from Marika Partridge. You know you can listen to our programs for absolutely free on our website, www.thisamericanlife.org. Or you know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德和我制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、苏珊·伯顿和南希·厄普代克参与。本节目的特约编辑有杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。托德·巴克曼、赛斯·林德和西娅·查洛纳提供了制作帮助。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。今天的音乐帮助来自玛丽卡·帕特里奇。你知道你可以免费在我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org上收听我们的节目。或者你知道你可以从audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们的节目音频。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who wants you to know just one thing. Really, just one little thing. One, and one thing only.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督来自托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他只想让你知道一件事。真的，只有一小件事。一，也只有一件事。
You know why other people steal? To buy drugs, which is disgusting. You know what I use this for? My rent and car insurance.
你知道别人为什么偷东西吗？为了买毒品，这太恶心了。你知道我用这些钱干什么吗？付房租和车险。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
I didn't really think of it as a sin at the time. I thought of it as an opportunity.
我在当时并没有真的认为那是一种罪。我认为那是一个机会。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台。